Hallo, schon jemand da?
Aber wisst ihr, was ich sehe?
Twitch ist wieder der Meinung, ich habe keine Qualitätsoptionen heute.
Und heute sind es 720p, 60fps.
Ich habe das Gefühl, Twitch hat da irgendwas geändert.
Weil ich hatte früher immer, immer Quality-Optionen.
Und in letzter Zeit immer nur Source oder Auto.
Ich weiß nicht, was da los ist.
Ich hatte jetzt zwei Monate lang immer Quality-Optionen.
Immer.
Aber jetzt nicht.
Und ich weiß nicht, warum, ehrlich zu sein.
Ich meine, habe ich zu hohe Bitrate?
Ich habe ja nichts geändert.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, ich kann nicht zu hohe Bitrate haben.
Ich habe ja nichts getan, hat sich.
Ich gucke mir das jetzt gerade mal an.
Videostatistik anzeigen.
Ja, exakt.
Kann das sein, dass man das nicht mal angezeigt kriegt?
Leute, kriegt ihr noch, wenn ihr...
Warte mal.
Wenn ihr euch die Videostatistik anzeigen lasst, ne, von meinem Video,
kriegt ihr dann auch angezeigt, wie viel Bitrate das ist.
Das steht bei mir jetzt gar nicht mehr drin.
Warum?
Wo ist das hin?
Schau Video-Stats.
Naja, das zeigt bei mir nichts mehr an.
Das zeigt bei mir...
Ah, ja, doch, Playback-Rate.
Playback-Rate.
Ah, ja, ich musste mal richtig gucken.
Doch, Playback-Rate steht da.
Ich glaube, Playback-Rate ist, ähm, ist das...
Ach, auf Deutsch heißt es Speicherauslastung, okay.
Ähm, weil, dann haben sie das einfach nur falsch übersetzt.
Weil, wenn ich mir das auf Englisch im Browser angucke, heißt es Playback-Rate.
6000 Kilowitsch per...
Also, das passt.
Das habe ich auch genau eingestellt.
Das muss...
Oh, ich muss mein Bot noch einstellen.
Mein Bot ist immer noch der Meinung, ich bin heute ziemlich im Arsch.
Das bin ich zwar auch, aber...
Ach, komm, ich lasse den Text jetzt einfach.
Ich lasse den Text jetzt einfach drinnen stehen.
Scheiß drauf.
Ähm, ich würde dir gerne ein Google Drive-Link für Gameplay zukommen lassen, aber halt nicht öffentlich.
Also, per DN oder so ähnlich.
Ähm...
Kannst du mir...
Kannst du mir das per YouTube-PN schicken, oder...
Keine Ahnung, per...
Antibusiness-E-Mail, oder...
Per Twitch-PM, keine Ahnung.
Am liebsten eigentlich per YouTube-PN.
So.
Ich würde sagen, machen wir mal den Text weg.
Hallo, Rom...
Romagno.
Wir spielen heute mal ein Puzzle-Game, was ich schon immer mal spielen wollte, was ich seit 2000...
Ach, ich weiß es nicht.
2000...
Moment, man kann das doch in Steam nachgucken, seit wann ich das in...
In der Bibliothek habe, oder?
Runtergeladen?
Ne, sieht man nicht mehr.
Keine Ahnung, gefühlt seit 8 Jahren oder so auf Steam habe.
Das Game kam raus 2000...
8.
Ich habe das schon ewig auf Steam.
Ich wollte das schon immer mal spielen.
Und ich habe es nie über die ersten 2-3 Levels raus geschafft.
Obwohl es nicht...
Obwohl es nicht wirklich schwierig ist.
Aber ich dachte mir, das ist ein wunderbares Game für Livestream, weil...
Ich kann Chat lesen und wir können schwätzen.
Und weil es hat kein Zeitlimit, oder sowas.
Das ist ein...
Das ist ein super entspannendes Puzzle-Game.
Schaut nicht, dass ich zu laut habe.
Nö, das passt so, ne?
Finde den Button für YouTube-PM nicht.
Äh, ich weiß mittlerweile gar nicht mehr, wie das funktioniert.
Okay, das erste sind ein paar Tutorial-Level.
Das ist...
Das ist Easy-Mode.
Das kriegt man natürlich...
Jetzt kriegt natürlich jeder hin.
Und ich habe es, wie gesagt, ich habe nur die ersten paar Levels je gespielt.
Ich wollte schon immer mal spielen.
Das gilt ja so als eines der coolsten Puzzle-Games überhaupt.
Max, was hältst du eigentlich von den ganzen IT-Consulting-Firmen?
Äh, in welchem Bereich?
Oder meinst du generell, dass sich jeder irgendwie Consultant, Junior-Consultant, hast du nicht gesehen, Consultant auf die Fahne schreibt?
Naja, die meisten Consultants kannst du erstmal in die Tonne kloppen.
Was viele dort können, ist, die können sich gut verkaufen.
Leute, die wirklich Ahnung haben, sind da recht rar gesät.
Steht noch auf dem Schild drauf.
Okay, ich muss zur Pipe rüber, zum Rohr.
Das hätte ich mir aber auch so überlegt.
Bam.
Easy.
Okay, die ersten Level sind ja immer einfach bei sowas.
Das wird aber bestimmt ziemlich schnell, ziemlich schwer.
Ah, der Subaru ist auch da.
Moin.
Irgendwer hat gefragt, wie mein Tag war.
Ich muss sagen, relativ entspannend.
Ich war ja heute nicht arbeiten.
Ist ja Montag.
Gehe ich ja nie arbeiten.
Deswegen war es heute entspannend.
Ich war im Bauhaus und habe nochmal fürs Hoftor Well...
Wie heißt das?
So Well...
Nicht Wellblech, sondern so Well...
Wie heißt das so?
So Wellending aus so durchsichtigem Plastik.
Wie nennt sich das?
So Wellenplatten oder so.
Gekauft.
Kann ich dann nämlich hinters Hof.
Hoftor machen und dann kann die Katz, die ich mir hole, nicht durchs Hoftor klettern.
Meine alte Katz konnte auch so nicht durchs Hoftor klettern, weil die war einfach zu alt und ungelenkig dafür.
Aber wenn ich jetzt mir eine neue Katze hole oder zwei neue Katzen, dann habe ich Angst, dass die quasi das Hoftor hochgehen und dann durchs Hoftor klettern, weil das Hoftor hat halt relativ große Löcher drin.
Da mache ich jetzt die Platten dahinter.
Das ist halt glatt.
Da kann keine Katze hochklettern.
Und dann sind die halt da.
Was gerade die Management-Consulting-Firmen sind, bei Arbeitnehmer ja nicht gern gesehen, gehen in eine Firma rein, schmeißen die Hälfte raus, das ganze Konzept durcheinander oder verschwinden.
Es kommt drauf an, in welchem Bereich die sind.
Also wenn man sich, wenn man sich für irgendwas und die Firma sagt, hey, wollen wir uns nicht selbst drum kümmern oder irgendwas, wo wir keine Ahnung von haben und wir holen.
Wir wollen uns irgendeinen, der sich das auskennt, jemand holt.
Da sehe ich überhaupt nichts Schlimmes dabei.
Das Problem ist eher, dass die meisten Consulting-Leute halt einfach Schwätzer sind.
Wir hatten mal auf der Arbeit, hatten wir mal Consulting-Typen da aus den USA von irgendeiner Firma, die sich mit so Cloud-Gedöns auskennt, will jetzt den Namen nicht sagen.
Und die haben ab dem zweiten Tag, also sie waren den ersten Tag da, haben was gemacht.
Und am zweiten Tag...
Am zweiten Tag haben sie festgestellt, oh, wir sind ja quasi so mitten in Frankfurt, da können wir jetzt mal alle, alle möglichen German-Spezialitäten ausprobieren.
Und haben sich dann ab mittags, dem zweiten Tag, noch ein German-Bier reingehauen und waren eigentlich zu nichts mehr zu gebrauchen.
Das hat sich natürlich nicht gelohnt, ne?
Tofu, Tofu?
Moin Max, wie geht's?
Oh, mir geht's gut.
Wie gesagt, ich muss heute nicht arbeiten gehen.
Naja, ich muss wahrscheinlich hier mich runterhängen lassen.
Aufwachen.
Gutes Video über andere Viren-Software.
THX.
Oh.
Oh, da müssen wir jetzt ein bisschen aufpassen.
Konnte man die Bälle nicht irgendwie wieder abmachen?
Ne, das ging, das ging mit anderen.
Ich glaub, meine Baukünste erreichen hier schnell ihr Limit in dem Game.
Hey Max, was war dein größter Scam deines Lebens, wo du, wo du gescamt wurdest?
Wo du richtig scammerst wurdest.
Oh, da muss ich mir mal Gedanken drüber machen.
Das Größte, wo ich beschissen wurde.
Hä?
Weiß, fällt's nicht ein?
Fällt das jetzt nicht ein?
Also, wo ich mich richtig verarscht, wo ich mir richtig verarscht vorkam,
das ist aber bestimmt nicht der größte Scam-Ass meines Lebens,
wo ich mir richtig verarscht vorkam, war bei meinem neuen Unity-Media-Anschluss,
als ich, ähm,
Dual-Stack-Live bekommen hab.
Das war die größte, größte Verarschung, was Provider-mäßig bisher so passiert ist.
Damals war es ja so, damals konntest du, wenn du ein Handy hattest bei der Telekom,
also bei, bei, weiß ich nicht, ob die auch T-Mobile hießen damals,
also wenn man ein Handy hatte, da in diesem Telekom-Netz,
die hatten damals mobil keine IPv6-Adressen
und ich hatte keine Möglichkeit, mich vom Handy mehr daheim einzuladen.
Was ich regelmäßig benutzt hab.
Ich hab VPN angemacht auf dem Handy,
hab dann Mails daheim gelesen, hab mir irgendwelche Sachen gesynkt und alles
und das ging dann auf einmal nicht mehr, weil Unity-Media der Meinung war, wir machen Dual-Stack-Live.
Aber was, was, was war so der größte Scam-Ass? Ich weiß es nicht.
Größte Scam-Ass?
Wow.
Was ist das?
The fuck?
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass du spielst.
so wie ich jetzt... Also wenn ich jetzt...
Mir fällt jetzt nichts ein. Das wurde schon nicht so
richtig verarscht.
Ich überlege gerade.
Ich meine, das wurde ja schon jeder ein bisschen...
Wurde ja schon jeder gescampt.
Ich mache mir gerade echt Gedanken. Was war denn das, wo ich bisher
am meisten mal gescampt wurde von irgendwas?
Zwei irgendwelche Mädels außen
vor, die einem komische Dinge erzählt haben,
was da nicht so war. Aber das ist ja nicht... Das ist ja nicht
Scam. Ähm...
Was? Wo wurde ich mal
gescampt so richtig?
Ich muss mir da mal Gedanken
zu machen. Fällt mir gerade nichts ein.
Wahrscheinlich wisst ihr das besser,
weil ich das mal in irgendeinem Video erzählt habe und jetzt gar nicht
dran denke.
Hey, hast du... Hast auf Twitch
eine P... P... mit dem Google
Drive Link erhalten? Auf Twitch?
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie man
auf Twitch...
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie man auf Twitch
Messages sich anguckt.
Fällt mir gerade auf.
Wie gucke ich mir auf Twitch
Messages... Warte mal.
Dashboard?
Ich weiß nicht, wo man Messages sich anguckt
auf Twitch.
Wo geht denn das?
Videomanager? Nach Nachrichten,
da ist es ja.
Angeblich habe ich keine Message erhalten.
Eingang? Nichts.
Sonstiges?
Sonst... Twitch?
Please! Was ist denn das für eine Logik?
Bei Twitch hat man unter Messages
Eingang, Ausgang, Sonstiges
und jetzt ratet mal...
Chat, ratet mal, in welchem Ordner eine neue Message
landet.
Eingang, Ausgang oder Sonstiges?
Äh, der Bot schreibt
sinnloses Zeug, das ist noch von gestern.
Aber das Ganze ist mal
aufzuklären. Die Message von ihm ist
in Sonstiges gelandet. Also nicht
Eingang oder so, wie man das erwarten würde.
Ich habe unter Sonstiges
sogar mittlerweile einige PNs.
Die habe ich alle überhaupt nicht gesehen.
WTF?
Wo ist denn da...
Ist auch geil. Wer guckt denn bitteschön in Sonstiges?
Wo ist das? Was für ein Schwachsinn wieder?
Okay, aber ich habe es
gekriegt, die PN. Alles gut.
Sonstiges normal, ja.
Ich muss mal meinem Bot beibringen, dass der
nicht so komische Dinger schreibt. Moment.
Okay. Nightbot.
Wo ist der Nightbot? Hier ist der
Nightbot. So.
Nightbot Timers.
Da ändern wir jetzt mal
den Text.
Add Woblos.
Wenn ich
etwas übersehe,
dann...
So, ich habe den Bot-Text mal geupdatet.
Easy.
BDO-Frage. Kann man...
Was kann mir ein Crystal für Arm
more claimen und kann zwischen
Gathering, Fishing, Training und Processing auswählen?
Was für ein Anfang? Kein Schimmer.
Ich sage doch, ich bin der
bestausgerüstete BDO-Nob. Ich habe von dem
Game überhaupt keine Ahnung.
Heute war der eine auf Bauingenieur, ja.
Was denkst du
über die Sicherheit von Online-Banking?
Gerade mit Mobile-Tan und
Banking-App auf einem Handy sehe ich, dass...
...doch etwas kritisch, ja.
Ich auch.
Ja, kann ich dazu nicht sagen.
Aber man darf nicht vergessen,
die ganzen Scammers-Leute
sind halt immer sehr
kreativ, ne?
Moment, was muss ich
hier überhaupt machen?
Ah, das sind die Dinger, die man wieder wegmachen kann.
New Go-Balls.
Ah, ich glaube, ich habe jetzt gecheckt,
wie das funktioniert.
Ich muss hier nach oben bauen.
Ups, so war das
jetzt nicht gedacht, wie ich das gemacht habe.
Ich muss das hier nach oben bauen.
Dann kann ich hier unten abmachen.
Irgendwie so.
Moment, ich glaube, ich mache das aber falsch.
Kann ich das nicht irgendwie das Ding
an die Wand sticken lassen?
Auf, Ball.
Ball, geh weg.
Das bleibt nicht an der Wand hängen, ne?
Die kleben nicht so wirklich an der Wand.
Das wird doch niemals was, wenn das da abgeht.
Ich glaube, meine
Baukünste failen.
Failen gerade.
Das klebt da gar nicht gerade an der Wand.
Warum klebt das nicht an der Wand?
Ach so, doch, funktioniert doch.
Easy.
Oh.
Oh, ich sehe schon,
das Spiel wird gefummelt.
Aber ich wollte es ja so.
Ich gucke gleich in den Chat, falls ich was
übersehen habe.
Oh, ich habe Angst,
dass das gleich abbricht.
Was, nur zwei Stück? Das geht aber besser.
Ich kann das hier noch abmachen, das hier noch
abmachen.
Ähm.
Das da?
Okay.
Wir haben es gepackt. Neun von zwei.
Ja, Sebarro, frag mal den Friseur.
Heute kommt der Mercy-Nerf.
Oh, nice.
Nice. Ich freue mich ja.
Da muss ich ehrlich sagen, ich bin ja normalerweise
nicht so schadenfroh, also nicht so extrem
schadenfroh. Ich kann mich jetzt nicht so sehr
am Leid anderer
erfreuen.
Aber
den Mercy-Mains
in Overwatch, den gönn ich's.
What?
Den Mercy-Mains gönn ich's.
Was muss man hier machen?
In das Menü soll ich gucken. Okay.
Menü?
35 more balls.
Können wir alles hin.
Ach, hier unten. Ne, das Menü.
Wow. Okay, wir müssen
nach oben hin.
Äh. Okay, das ist jetzt,
das wird jetzt ein bisschen komplizierter.
So wird Bubble-Tea hergestellt.
Ähm.
Was wird denn an Mercy genervt?
Also, ich weiß nicht, ob das noch der aktuelle
Stand ist. Letztes Mal, was ich mal gelesen hab, ist, dass
du nicht mal instant retzen kannst.
Selbst in der Ultimate.
Das,
ich glaub, der ne Ult kürzer ist.
Und
ich glaube, die Zeit, wie du fliegen kannst, wird
auch irgendwie verringert oder so.
Bin ich mir jetzt aber nicht mal ganz sicher.
The fuck?
Oh, ich seh schon, das wird, das wird...
Irgendwas.
Okay, ich glaube, das ist nicht gedacht, dass es da so stehen bleibt, oder?
Krassen
Baukünste.
Ich, ich, ich setz da jetzt einfach mal irgendwas aneinander.
Easy Clap. Easy.
Nein!
Fuck.
Das ist ja hardcore, ey.
Wahrscheinlich kann ich das einfach irgendwie vollbauen
hier. Ich mein, ich brauch ja bloß 8.
Ich brauch ja nur 8 Goos.
Ist ja nix.
Zack, zack, zack, zack. Easy.
Geschafft. Ähm.
Woher kommt der Hate gegen Mercy-Mains?
Als ich noch
gespielt hab, waren die Hanzo-Mains die
morgens die keiner machte.
Naja, Hanzo-Mains, ich glaub, ich hab das Gefühl, das ist ein bisschen weniger
geworden. Außerdem heißt das ja nicht Hanzo,
sondern, wenn man cool ist, ist das Hanzo.
Ähm.
Ich glaube, der hauptsächliche Mercy-
Hate liegt daran,
im Charakter,
im Charakter selbst.
Mercy ist der Held,
der mit Abstand
für den wenigsten Einsatz
die den
das Höchste bringt, ja.
Und es ist schon in gewisser
Weise frustrierend, wenn man sich überlegt, man kann
sowas wie Tracer, Genji gut spielen,
was saumäßig schwierig ist.
Und du siehst irgendjemand, der quasi Mercy
linke Maustaste
gedrückt halten kann, ab und zu mal Q und
zwei Leute instant retzen und hat damit im Endeffekt
fast mehr Einfluss auf das Spiel wie du,
der sich übelst die Seele aus dem Leib spielt.
Das ist glaube ich der hauptsächliche Hate
gegen Mercy.
Dazu kommt halt auch, dass man sieht,
wenn man sich die Match-Historie
von den Leuten anguckt,
dass du welche hast, die waren halt
keine Ahnung, die haben hier ihre Mercy
One-Tricks gespielt, sind dann halt quasi
gewesen, irgendwie Gold, Platin, Gold,
Gold, Platin, Platin, vielleicht mal Diamond
oder so. Und jetzt die letzten zwei Seasons
halt GM. Das ist halt lächerlich.
Für nichts
können im Endeffekt.
Ich meine, man darf sich nicht überlegen,
es heißt Grandmaster und du kannst
mit links klicken Grandmaster werden.
Das ist halt auch nicht so.
Vom Design her auch alles nicht so
tolle.
Woher kam er?
Was sagst du denn
zu Slayers angekündigtem Ende?
Ich weiß gar nicht, was du meinst.
Hä? Was wurde, was ist
zu Ende?
Ich weiß nicht, was du meinst.
Oh, das wird
eine Balancier-Geschichte jetzt hier.
Ich glaube, ich muss mich hier
erstmal hier runterhangeln,
die Balls aufsammeln
und dann wieder nach oben.
Oh, da bin ich ja mal gespannt, wie das
funktioniert. Das müssen wir
auf jeden Fall mit den grünen
Max
mit den grünen Balls machen,
weil die lassen sich ja wieder
abkletten.
Ich habe mir
absichtlich ein sehr entspanntes Game für heute
ausgesucht.
Ich glaube, das wird echt kompliziert
später.
Komm her jetzt.
Komm her.
Zack, dann bauen wir mal wieder hoch.
Dann bauen wir auf der anderen Seite
runter. Kann man eigentlich speichern?
Nee, das geht natürlich nicht. Wäre ja auch bescheuert,
wenn das funktioniert.
Was? Ich muss eigentlich gar nicht Pause machen.
Das Spiel hat überhaupt kein Zeitlimit.
What?
Chef.
Was ist das?
Das ist das gleiche.
Sehr viele, die Goldblatt waren, wurden auf einmal Master.
Es gab vier Resets von der Season bis heute.
Also, was ich so alles in allem gelesen habe...
Äh...
Ah!
Diese Dinger...
Diese Dinger machen immer einen Schritt zurück.
Kann das sein?
Lol.
Jetzt habe ich mich selbst resetet.
Perfekt, Max. Ganz, ganz clever gemacht.
Ich muss
die ganzen Teile machen.
Okay, aber jetzt weiß ich es.
Die resetten mich.
Auch gut.
Hallo.
Ich will das Ding da anklicken.
Und nicht runterfallen.
Blitz.
Ah, man kann hier nicht durchtracken.
Auch gut.
So, und jetzt müssen wir hier runterbauen
und die anderen holen.
Hey Max, welche Programmiersprache
empfiehlst du zum Anfangen?
Ähm...
Das hatten wir gestern schon mal kurz.
Auf welcher Plattform
willst du programmieren?
Oder willst du einfach nur ein bisschen warm werden?
Also hast du was Konkretes im Kopf, was du machen willst?
Oder auf welcher Plattform programmierst du?
Also quasi Mac, Windows oder...
Wo bist du unterwegs?
Ups, das war jetzt eine blöde Idee.
Ähm...
Ohne Ankündigung 70 Viewer.
Gestern war krass, ne?
Komplett ohne Ankündigung irgendwie
zwischenzeitlich 140.
Und ich habe
ein paar Windows Forms Sachen zusammengeklickt.
Okay,
es war Wochenende, aber trotzdem.
Windows.
Also wenn du Windows entwickelst, kann ich dir
empfehlen, lad dir Visual Studio runter.
Ich zeig das mal. Wir können das ja heute
alles mal ein bisschen entspannt machen.
Ähm...
Ich mach mal kurz ein Chrome auf.
Ich zeig dir mal, was du dir da
besorgen kannst.
Lad dir einfach das hier runter.
Moment.
Capture.
Window Capture.
Das da.
Lad dir einfach die
Visual Studio Community Edition runter.
Das da ist komplett kostenlos.
Auch wenn das Internet hier gerade ein bisschen lahm ist.
Wobei ich glaube eher Microsoft ist lahm.
Oh! Try Microsoft Edge.
Fast Secure Browser.
Also lad dir am besten Visual Studio Community
2017 runter. Kost nix.
Und ähm...
Dann schnappst du dir das
Galileo Open
Book C Sharp.
Das da.
Und fängst an.
Das ist das Beste, was ich dir zum Einstieg unter Windows empfehlen kann.
Nicht retry.
Zoom.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh, ich ahne
Schlimmes. Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Das wird nix.
Ach du Scheiße.
Lol.
Komm, schnell, schnell, schnell.
Two Balls. Zack, zack.
Bevor das wieder umkippt.
Kippt ja gar nicht um.
Dann können wir noch ein bisschen
besseren Score hier rausholen.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Nicht, dass es jetzt reißt.
Okay, das kann ich
hier nicht mehr abmachen jetzt.
Okay, continue.
Nice, Max lahm hat übergotten. Die Welt-Streams sind die besten.
Find ich auch.
Macht mir auch am meisten Bock.
Übrigens heute, ne. Ich muss mich ja mal wieder
über YouTube auslassen.
Ich hab ja auch ein Video hochgeladen.
Über Virenscanner.
Und es gibt Videos.
Da...
Da nervts
mich einfach. Das sind halt Videos,
wo vielleicht manchmal was fällt,
was dem einen oder anderen nicht so gefällt.
Zum Beispiel gibt es bestimmt Leute,
die haben sich einen Virenscanner gekauft
und die finden es doof, dass ich nicht sage,
ihr Virenscanner ist der beste.
Und ich würde ihnen empfehlen, einfach Windows Defender
oder gar nix zu verwenden.
Sag ich das ja in dem Video.
Und das sind dann solche Videos,
wo ich einfach mal instant
10, 15 D-Abos kriege.
Das nervt mich.
Ich mein, klar kannst du jetzt
im Endeffekt sagen, was juckt's mich.
Ich mein, den meisten Leuten gefällt's doch und alles.
Das stimmt schon. Aber das nervt mich irgendwie
immer.
Und das trotz krassem Abo-Sellout.
Video heute wieder.
Mir hat das
Bad Company 1 Gameplay gefallen.
Ja, das war auch mal wieder was.
Das musste ja mal wieder was sein.
Und es hat letztens einer in den Comments gefragt,
so nach dem Motto, ist dir das wichtiger,
dass neue Leute
abonnieren, anstatt dass es den
Bestehenden gefällt und sonst was.
Man kann sich auch echt
an allem stören, was ich sag.
Ich mein,
das eine hat ja mit dem anderen nix zu tun.
Ich muss ja im Video kurz und knackige
Sache sagen können, die passt.
Und kann da nicht erst mal 5 Minuten
philosophieren.
Was mir am besten gefällt oder so.
Deswegen sag ich da mittlerweile mal
einen Standard-Abo-Spruch und gut, erst
lass das mit dem Abo-Sellout lieber aus.
Das bringt unglaublich viel.
Kann sich das gar nicht
vorstellen.
Deswegen, ich hab ja auch früher immer
gesagt, so ein Blödsinn, ja.
Aber es ist einfach so, dass viele
Leute die Videos gucken und sogar
regelmäßig gucken. Ich seh das ja über die Startseiten
und so. Das heißt, die Leute gucken die Videos über die Startseite
und kriegen sie auch empfohlen über
die Startseite oder über Videos, was sie nicht
empfohlen bekommen würden, wenn sie nicht
mich öfters gucken würden oder
nicht Leute, die ähnliche
Videos machen zu meinen öfters gucken würden.
Und ich seh einfach, dass
total wenige Abos daraus resultieren.
Und seit ich jetzt angefangen hab
einmal im Video drauf hinzuweisen, ist das
viel mehr. Das ist wirklich extrem viel
mehr. Und
die
ähm, die ganzen
Social-Plate-Statistiken, die man quasi
von außen sieht,
sind ja nur die halbe Wahrheit.
Ähm, wenn was Social-Plate ansteht,
keine Ahnung, ich mache irgendwie,
ich muss jetzt mal gucken,
Social-Plate sagt
aktuell ich mache am Tag
Daily Durchschnitt
44 Abos, steht jetzt da.
Na, das ist im Vergleich zu
letztes Jahr immer noch immens.
Die letzten, die letzten
zwei Jahre hab ich Minus-Abos gemacht, weil ich
weil ich kaum was hochgeladen hab. Mittlerweile
bin ich schon wieder bei ungefähr 44 am Tag.
Und
äh, wo wollte ich jetzt
eigentlich drauf raus? Lull.
Ah ja, genau.
Das ist überhaupt nichts, nichts großartig aussagt.
In Wirklichkeit sind das viel, viel,
viel, viel mehr als 44 Abos
am Tag. Aber, dazu kommen
natürlich, wenn man schon länger dabei ist,
dann hast du halt immer Konten, die
inaktiv, was muss ich eigentlich machen?
Ah.
Äh, immer Konten, die inaktiv werden, die gelöscht werden
und alles mögliche in der Richtung.
Plus halt auch Leute, die de-Abon.
Also sprich, das sind ja nur die Abos, die übrig
bleiben. Was muss ich denn hier
eigentlich machen jetzt?
Fly. Ach, ich glaube
ich muss hier, ich muss hier nen
Ich muss, muss an die Balls nen
Luftballon dranhängen, ne?
Also ich find, die Ideen
für die Rätsel hier sind wirklich clever.
Auch wenn es noch die Tutorial-Welten
sind. Max,
wie stehst du eigentlich zu SpaceX?
Interessierst du dich dafür überhaupt?
Also ich hab mich relativ wenig
beschäftigt.
Beschäftige ich mich mit, äh, was so,
was so die privaten
Raumfahrer
da und dann, die gibt's ja nicht nur SpaceX,
es gibt ja auch noch, ich hab vergessen,
wie das andere heißt.
Was die so machen,
ich krieg immer mit, ah, mal ne Rakete wieder
abgestürzt, mal irgendein Satellit kaputt, mal
hat alles geklappt, das Ding ist wieder gelandet.
Für, ähm, so
Universum, Theorie und Weltraum
und sowas interessier ich mich extrem.
Ich guck sauviele.
Sauviele, ähm,
ich hab viele, viele YouTube-Channels abonniert und guck da
sauviele Videos in der Richtung. Was jetzt
allerdings SpaceX und sowas macht an sich,
äh, pff, juckt mich nicht,
muss ich sagen.
Und ich glaube auch nicht, wo wir gerade beim
Thema sind,
ich glaube nicht, dass, ähm,
wann, wann, wann will
Elon Musk auf den Mars fliegen? 2020?
Oder wann war das?
Das kann ich mir auf dem besten Bild nicht vorstellen,
dass das funktioniert.
Ich kann mir vorstellen,
dass, ähm, sie,
oder was, 2000, wann, wann wollte der,
ne, ähm,
wann wird der losfliegen? 2030?
Oder wann war das?
2022.
Irgendwie so. Ähm,
so, und
ich kann mir vorstellen,
dass sie
da irgendwas bauen und auch irgendwie Leute
reinsetzen.
Aber wenn das wirklich starten soll,
bevor ich nicht ausgehe,
vor allem nicht, äh, termingerecht,
dann
hab ich die doofe Vermutung,
dass
wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal die Leute lebend
auf den Mars ankommen werden.
Ähm,
geschweige denn,
die ganze Sache, irgendeiner überlebt von denen,
die da mitmachen.
Magst du Ananas
auf Pizza? Ja, auch wenn das laut Gordon Ramsay
voll verwerflich ist, mag ich das.
Hältst du Zeitreisen
für möglich realistisch?
Äh, in die Zukunft?
Ja, in die Vergangenheit nicht.
So, was muss ich jetzt
hier machen? Muss ich jetzt
rüberfliegen? Ne.
Äh.
Ah, ah, ich glaub, ich hab's gecheckt,
was ich machen muss.
Ich muss, oh, oh, oh, das wird,
das wird ein Balanceakt hier.
Okay.
Funktioniert.
Okay, wir bauen das jetzt
mal möglichst, ach du Scheiße.
Wir bauen
das jetzt hier mal möglichst gerade.
Wow!
Ah, da oben sind auch Stacheln.
Ähm.
Oh,
da muss ich jetzt ein bisschen aufpassen.
Ich lese gleich den Rest
im Chat.
Die Physik der Gobell ist ein bisschen
gewöhnungsbedürftig.
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, das ist knapp,
das ist knapp, das ist, oh, das ist knapp.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein,
oh, fuck.
Oh, oh, okay.
Hä, das ist schwieriger, als ich mir das
vor, nein, nein, nein, okay, passt das?
Das ist schwieriger, als ich mir das vorgestellt
hab gerade. Was hab ich da eigentlich
für ein komisches Ding gebaut? Das ist doch komplett
sinnlos.
Nein, nein, ich wollte
den Ball doch gar nicht dahin machen.
Fuck. Ich bau hier einen Scheiß
zusammen, äh, ist der Wahnsinn.
Oh, das ist,
das ist echt knapp, was ich hier baue.
Ah!
Oh, oh.
Mit dem letzten Gobell.
Hahaha.
Monka ist,
was ist das für eine Konstruktion,
was für ein Konstrukt hier.
Aber es hat geklappt.
Okay, ich muss mal kurz
Chat hochscrollen.
Hallo, Mr. Unlocker.
Ähm, der Alex fragt, was meine
Lieblings-IDE ist.
Also, ich muss sagen, unter
Windows, auch wenn
Microsoft-Produkte immer viel Hate abbekommen,
aber gegen Visual Studio kann man
eigentlich nichts Schlechtes sagen.
Es ist alles mal,
also, ich kann nicht sagen, was meine,
was meine, äh,
gehassteste, beziehungsweise meine unbeliebteste IDE
ist, und das ist eindeutig Eclipse.
Sowas aufgeblasenes,
hässliches, hab ich ja
selten benutzen müssen.
Ähm,
aber unter Windows muss ich sagen,
Visual Studio ist super für alles, was,
äh, halt, ja, halt, Windows und .NET
mäßig ist, und für C++
finde ich, was auch ziemlich
gut ist, ist der Qt
Disney, äh,
Creator
heißt er, Creator.
Der Qt Creator, der ist auch
super.
Also, ich würd sagen, Visual Studio
und, äh, Qt Creator.
Wenn du TV schaust, was schaust
du eher an Dokus oder Serienfilme?
Also, Talkshows danach, ich guck eigentlich gar
keinen Fernseher.
Also, wenn, wenn ich mal
irgendwas gucke,
dann, dann
vielleicht irgendwelche Doku-Geschichten
oder so, ich guck eigentlich nix.
Ich guck eigentlich, ich, das, mittlerweile muss ich sagen,
ich, ich bin ja, ich bin jetzt, wie gesagt,
ich bin 84 geboren, ja,
ähm, das ist eigentlich so die, die letzte Generation,
die so noch mit Fernseher aufgewachsen ist,
zu der ich gehöre.
Also, noch ohne YouTube und Internet und Zeug.
Ich bin da quasi so die
letzte Generation, die das betrifft.
Ähm,
aber ich glaube, ich,
im Umkehrfall war ich einer der ersten,
der quasi,
oder gehöre ich auch zur ersten Generation,
wo viele komplett auf Fernseh
verzichten.
Ich guck, ich guck eigentlich keinen Fernseher.
Fernseh in 2k18, äh,
in 2k18, Leute, ja.
A real tower of goo.
Ich hab die Story von
dem Spiel immer noch nicht verstanden, falls da jetzt wirklich
einer hat.
Wie hoch muss ich denn?
Okay, das ist echt hoch.
Da, da müssen wir, da müssen wir
ein bisschen breiter anfangen.
Achtung, Max Architekten-Skills
sind jetzt gefragt.
Maximum
Architekt-Skills.
So, ich hoffe mal, das ist
breit genug.
Wir machen jetzt so eine Art Eiffelturm hier.
Ich glaube, das ist das letzte,
das letzte Level
zu, vom,
vom Tutorial.
Oh, das ist jetzt schon Shep.
Das ist jetzt schon Shep.
Okay, wir gleichen das mal ein bisschen aus.
Wie viel? 25, na gut,
ich hab ja auch ganz schön viele.
Das ist nicht gerade, oder, was ich hier baue.
Oh, jetzt, oh,
es kommt auch noch Wind dabei. Ach, du.
Okay, dann müssen wir das hier ein bisschen,
bisschen schwerer bauen, als auf der anderen Seite.
Oh, fuck,
guck mal, wie hoch wir da müssen. Oh, nee,
das wird nix. Ach, du Scheiße.
Nee, das wird nix.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, hey, Moment.
Es lebt, es lebt.
Oder auch nicht.
Scheiße.
Ich hab, oh, Mann, das wird nix.
Ach, du Scheiße. Ich baue jetzt, ich baue jetzt
einfach so schnell. Der hat ja auch geschrieben,
ich soll schnell, oh, fuck, ey. Warte mal,
jetzt kann ich doch rückgängig machen, oder?
Ich glaube, ich muss nochmal anfangen.
Das wird doch nix.
Scheiße.
Okay, wir fangen nochmal an.
Das musst du anders machen.
Das, das funktioniert so nicht. Okay,
wir müssen das breiter bauen.
So, hä?
Okay, okay, jetzt ist, jetzt ist es echt breit.
Was? Game is Black Desert?
Nein, nicht wirklich.
Ich weiß nicht, was der, hör nicht auf den
Nightbot, was der da erzählt. Der Nightbot hat keine Ahnung.
Okay, was gibt's
hier auf dem Schild? Go as fast as
you can. Okay, das ist halt, das, das heißt,
as fast as I can, das ist, das ist
die Taktik hier, oder was?
Go, go!
Jetzt, jawoll,
zackig, zackig, zackig, zackig, rein, rein, rein, rein,
rein, rein, rein, rein, rein.
Easy clap, easy clap, überhaupt kein Ding.
Überhaupt kein Ding.
Oh.
Heieieiei.
Max Nightbot labert wieder
scheiße. Ja, das stimmt nicht so ganz.
Was der geschrieben hat mit Game
Black Desert, das ist falsch.
Was ist
das Ziel von dem Spiel? Zur Röhre
zu kommen.
Wann das Subbutton kommt? Ich hab, wie gesagt, ich hab Twitch
immer noch nicht angefragt, angeschrieben.
Benutzt du denn ab und zu
dein Switch? Nee.
Das letzte, was ich drauf gespielt hab, ist Mario.
All I see. Nope.
Gibt ja nix.
Es gibt ja nix auf der Switch.
Da wird mir jetzt zwar der Nintendo, der, der
Nintendo-Fan widersprechen,
aber was gibt's denn auf der Switch?
Ah, es gibt Zelda,
es gibt Mario, es gibt vielleicht noch Splatoon, wenn man
da drauf steht. Es gibt
dieses Mario-Rabbids-Spiel, wenn man da drauf
steht. Es gibt
ähm...
Was gibt's denn sonst auf der
Switch?
Moment, das gucken wir uns jetzt mal zusammen an.
Wir gucken uns jetzt mal, wir gucken
uns jetzt mal kurz die Switch-Games an.
Und dann sag ich euch,
was mir davon gefällt und was nicht, weil
ähm...
Upcoming für 2017? Nein.
Gibt's da keine Liste für
Switch-Spiele, die 2018 rausgekommen sind?
Das,
das überrascht mich jetzt aber.
Und vor allem 2017, nicht
2018.
Wo gibt's denn Switch-Spiele? Release-Liste aktueller?
Ja, gucken wir mal.
Guck mal, Best Switch-Games
2017.
Wenn man danach so... Guck, jetzt funktioniert... Guck mal,
jetzt kann ich mich sogar verschrieben, jetzt kann ich sogar sagen,
Best Swatch-Games
2017 funktioniert. Also,
gutes Game,
ähm...
Stimmt ganz okay.
Kann ich nix zu sagen, ich war noch nie
großer Splatoon-Fan.
Übrigens, weil jetzt sagt der Max Frist wieder, ich hab hier Trauben.
Also jetzt ne, nicht so...
Nicht, dass ich jetzt irgendwelche ungesunden Sachen
puttern würde oder so.
So.
Mario Kart 8 Deluxe.
Ist nicht übel.
Mario Kart 8
generell war nicht übel.
Wobei ich sagen muss,
ich finde, ich fand Mario Kart
war schon immer dadurch
gekennzeichnet, dass es absolut random
ist.
Aber ich hab persönlich den Eindruck, dass Mario
Kart 8 fast noch das
random-mixte Mario Kart überhaupt
ist.
Was mich ein bisschen genervt hat.
Ich fand das Mario Kart auf der Wii
richtig geil, ich fand
das auf dem DS richtig geil
und ich find Mario Kart 8
auch ganz gut, aber das ist
bei mir jetzt in meiner Mario Kart Liste
nicht so weit oben.
Wobei es mittlerweile viel mehr Strecken
und alles gibt als früher.
Was ich bis heute nicht verstanden hab, warum es Link
in einem Mario Kart Spiel gibt, aber wahrscheinlich,
weil Nintendo mittlerweile auch verstanden hat,
es geht da drum, was die Leute für Charaktere spielen
wollen, scheißegal, ob sie zum Universum gehören
oder nicht.
Okay.
Also, fangen wir mal an. Gutes Game.
Also auf jeden Fall, die ersten beiden absolut
Top Games. Gibt es nichts dazu
zu sagen, eines der besten Spiele,
die überhaupt
rausgekommen sind, so die ersten beiden.
Splatoon, wem es gefällt.
Mario Kart 8, auch nicht übel.
Mario und Rabbids, eigentlich auch ganz nett.
Ähm, ARMS.
Da muss ich sagen, bin ich ein bisschen
enttäuscht von Nintendo, was ARMS angeht.
Ähm, sie haben das im Vorfeld
angekündigt, als
ARMS eSports League
oder so, haben sie mal irgendwo erzählt, ja.
Nintendo ARMS is joining the world of eSports
bla bla bla bla bla.
Also so nach dem Motto, boah, wir haben ganz tolle Ambitionen
mit dem Game und jetzt
kam letztens die Message, ARMS
ist eingestellt.
Jawoll!
So macht man ein tolles Competitive Multiplayer
Spiel, indem man es ein paar Monate nach Release
einstellt. Das ist Easy Clap, das ist
ganz toll Nintendo. Ähm,
Xenoblade Chronicles 2
soll ziemlich gut sein.
Und das war's. Das heißt,
wir haben im Endeffekt zwei
Must Have Games, wofür es sich ohne
Frage lohnt, eine Switch zu kaufen.
Wenn man halt eine
Wii U hat, kann man sagen, hey, eigentlich könnte ich,
dass Zelda auch da drauf spielen. Aber mal angenommen, man hätte
keine Wii U, was ja viele Leute betrifft,
ähm,
also,
Must Have, ja. Allein schon für die zwei Games
kann man sich eine Switch kaufen.
Rest ist so, naja. Und
bis hier eigentlich auch noch alles ganz gut.
Also gäbe es, mal angenommen, es gefällt
einem alles das hier, gibt es
aktuell 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6,
7, nein, das
wie gesagt mittlerweile schon eingestellt, 1, 2, 3,
4, 5, sagen wir mal,
wir sagen mal 5 oder 6 Games.
Wobei es für mich halt
einfach nur zwei Games sind.
Und das ist einfach zu wenig.
Das ist einfach zu wenig. Ich meine, dass sich
da andere Konsolen wie jetzt, äh,
die neuen Sachen, die für Microsoft, äh,
für die Xbox rauskommen, auch noch
nicht so, äh,
nicht mit Ruhm bekleckert ist, macht's jetzt ja auch nicht
besser im Endeffekt.
So, was haben wir noch nach rechts?
Snipperclips. Nett.
Nett. Ja. Ähm.
Sonic Mania.
Soll ganz gut sein, kannst du aber glaube ich auch auf
allen anderen Plattformen spielen und hatte glaube ich FPS
Probleme auf das mit.
Ich weiß nicht, wie das neue Fire Emblem
ist.
Keine Ahnung. Wenn das was taugt, ist das
bestimmt auch ein ganz gutes Game.
Golf, sorry, was auch immer, kein Schimmer. Fast
Ares. Das ist dieses, dieses F-Zero,
was kein F-Zero ist, das ist aber auch irgendeine Neuauflage
von irgendwas altem, das soll auch ganz gut sein.
Äh, FIFA 18, die, die, die,
die, guck mal, da steht sogar P,
da ist sogar die PS4.
Da ist sogar die PS4-Packung auf der
Konsole und Dings, wenn man nach Switch sucht.
Äh, ähm,
beschissen ist die FIFA-Portierung
für FIFA um aller Zeiten für die Switch.
Ähm, eins, äh, 1-2
Switch, hör mal auf, da sag ich nix zu NBA,
juckt nicht. Steam-Dickwild
ist glaube ich ganz gut, aber es ist halt alles jetzt nix
wofür man nicht unbedingt eine Switch kaufen muss.
Wollfenstein muss man sich definitiv
keine Switch kaufen. Yooka-Laylee muss man sich
auch keine Switch verkaufen. Man kann es überall woanders
spielen. Äh, Sonic 2017,
nein. Nein.
Das neue Bomberman suckt auch.
Ähm, das ist auch ne Neuauflage von
irgendwas Altem.
Glaub ich.
Kommt mir irgendwie bekannt vor, also es ist doch schon ein bisschen älter.
Lego-Spiele gibt's auch überall anderes.
Was auch immer das hier ist, gibt's bestimmt
auch überall anders. Snake Pass gibt's auch überall
anders. Also das war's. Im Endeffekt bleiben
zwei Must-Have-Spiele für die, den Rest
gibt's auch für andere Plattformen. Im Prinzip
gibt's zwei Must-Have-Spiele
für die
Switch. Das ist das hier.
Und ein ziemlich gutes, wenn man auf sowas steht,
Xenoblades und dann, und
vielleicht noch Mario Kart. Also sag mal, das,
das, das
und Mario Kart. Da hast du
wirklich, wenn, mit viel Wohlwollen
hast du, kannst du dir, selbst wenn du hier die
andere noch mitnimmst, also
es kommt jeder auf, sagen wir mal, ungefähr
vier Spiele, die ihm gefallen könnten
auf der Switch zurzeit. Und
äh,
es ist halt ein bisschen wenig, ne?
Ah ja, Skyrim gibt's, hab ich vergessen. Gibt's das
mittlerweile schon? Gibt's eigentlich
Skyrim schon?
Wobei Skyrim für mich
natürlich auch kein Grund ist,
sich die Switch zu kaufen.
Außer, dass man es mitnehmen kann. Okay.
Wer Skyrim schon immer mal mobil spielen wollte,
ja, okay, okay. Aber
die beste
Skyrim-Version
krasst du definitiv auf dem PC.
Und man merkt
Skyrim mittlerweile an, dass es
in die Jahre gekommen ist. Ich weiß nicht, wie oft
wollen sie denn Skyrim noch raushauen? Skyrim
gibt's ja gefühlt quasi für, für alles.
Das
kam, wann kam Skyrim raus?
Kann ich mal mal richtig reden, äh,
äh, Skyrim kam 2011 oder so raus?
Skyrim released
in
2011, Ende 2011
kam das raus.
Ich mein, überlegt mal, das Spiel ist sieben Jahre alt
und da gibt's jetzt neu, das wird
als grandios geil und neu
äh, angeprieselt auf sieben Jahre
später auf, das kommt.
Irgendwann ist ja auch mal, ist, ist ja mal
irgendwie, ist auch mal gut mit Skyrim.
Okay. Bridge Builder.
Bridge Builder Style. Nein.
So funktioniert das definitiv nicht.
Ich muss, ich muss an, ich muss das,
warte mal, ich mach mal anders. Schwachsinn.
Ich muss da ein bisschen nach hinten bauen.
Es ist eigentlich ziemlich easy.
So muss man das machen. Wir müssen da erstmal
ordentlich nach hinten so Gewicht
dran bauen, dann können wir nach vorne weitermachen.
Irgendwie so.
Ich glaub, das passt schon, was ich da mache.
So halbwegs.
Naja. Fast.
Ha! Krasse, krasse
Buildingskills, äh.
Vielleicht soll ich das noch ein bisschen hier
zusammenbauen. Ich seh halt auch die Hälfte
irgendwie nicht, ne?
Ich glaub, das, was ich hier mache, ist irgendwie ne ziemlich dämliche
Idee.
Das funktioniert so nicht.
Ich glaub, ich fang nochmal neu an.
Warte mal, Leute, ich fang nochmal neu an. Das klappt, das klappt
so nicht. Das ist bescheuert.
Okay.
Im Prinzip ist das doch ganz einfach.
Zack. Zack.
Zack. Wir bauen jetzt einfach so
weit, bis es anfängt runterzufallen.
So, und wenn das
anfängt runterzufallen, bauen wir hier hinten
was dran.
Und dann zieht's das wieder hoch.
Ja?
Ich seh halt nix, so wirklich.
Und jetzt zieht's das, sollte es das,
naja.
Irgendwie sind meine Bridge-Builder-Sachen
jetzt auch nicht so toll.
Wie weit muss ich denn da
eigentlich? Ach, das ist ja gar nicht mal so
weit. Ach ja,
stimmt! Das neue Monster Hunter
ist ja am Start. Das wollte ich
ja eigentlich mit dem Fabian mal ausprobieren.
Max, was du da baust,
funktioniert nicht. Oder doch?
Nein, Max.
Max, das ist nix.
Max, das funktioniert so nicht.
Das ist ne ziemlich
bescheuerte Idee, was du hier baust.
Ich glaub, ich muss nochmal anfangen.
Fuck, ich bin
da zu dumm für, das gibt's doch nicht.
Okay, okay. Ganz, ganz, ganz
ruhig. Oder muss ich, warte mal,
ich baue nachher unten was. Hier unten kommt noch was hin?
Jawoll! Hier unten kommt noch, so ist das
gut. So.
Oh, fuck.
Das wollte ich gar nicht. Scheiße.
Kann ich schon mal rückgängig machen?
So, ja, so ist das schick.
Star-Tigor,
ja. Ist krasser Star-Tigor.
So, und
jetzt, jetzt weiß ich was
jetzt bauen wir hier hinten,
jetzt bauen wir hier hinten hoch
und lassen es einfach
zurückziehen.
So, genau. Okay.
So.
Das klappt, das klappt.
Oder auch nicht.
Fuck, man! Warum bin ich
denn so schlecht für dieses Game, ey?
Star-Tigor
am Werk, ey. Das wird
doch nie was!
Alter! Wie soll das was
werden?
Ach du Scheiße.
Na!
Schreckt! Oh, ich hab zu wenig
Balls. Fuck.
Okay, wie viel hab ich in 1?
Oh, nee, jetzt hab ich zu wenig Balls.
Ich glaub's nicht.
Kann ich noch irgendwo mal rückgängig machen?
Next MLG-Taktik, hochbauen, dann umfallen
lassen. Nee, das, pass mal auf.
Das ist gar nicht so schwer. Das machen wir jetzt einfach.
Machen wir das jetzt easy, als wär's
nix. Als wär's.
So.
Weiter. Zack.
So, easy Star-Tecors.
Guck mal, das ist doch überhaupt kein Ding.
Das kriegt doch, easy clap.
Ha!
Guck mal. Überhaupt kein Ding.
Man sollte nicht versuchen,
irgend so'n Scheiß zu bauen.
Sondern einfach geradeaus drüber.
Man muss ja auch nicht alles total
jetzt irgendwie überdenken.
Hochbauen steht auf'm Schild. Guck mal jetzt.
Hier. Guck mal.
Wie viele von 8 wir da kriegen.
Okay, was hab ich jetzt überlesen
im Chat? Zeig mal her. Ähm.
Ei, ei, ei.
Jetzt hab ich ganz viel verpasst, nachdem ich jetzt hier dieses komische
Teil erstmal bauen musste.
So, es gibt viele Diskussionen über Wii.
Äh, über was? Wie und Switch.
Snipperclips
ist der Kaufgrund für die Switch. Ja, genau.
Ähm.
Was sagst du zu Nintendo Labo?
Und du meinst dieses Papp-Zeug?
Ich find, das ist ne geile Idee.
Ich möchte jetzt anfangen
zu programmieren.
Kannst du mir Tipps für den Anfang geben?
Ja, das hatten wir gerade eben schon mal.
Ich würd dir empfehlen,
du bist wahrscheinlich unter Windows unterwegs.
Lad dir Wishlist Studio Community runter.
Community Edition runter.
Und fang an.
Nehm dir noch das Open Press, das Galileo
Open Press, die Chartbuche und fang an
zu lernen.
An welchem Level fängt man eigentlich in BDO
mit dem Grind an? Durchgängig.
Man levelt nicht über Quests. Quests braucht man nur
für Contribution Points. Man grindet quasi von
1 bis 60.
Du levelst ja auch in einem Tag
irgendwie bis 54 oder so.
Mittlerweile.
Ist da Fabian noch Friseur?
Soweit ich weiß, arbeitet er noch
hat's auch letztens mal im Stream bei sich gesagt.
Soweit ich weiß, er arbeitet noch im
Friseursalon.
Kümmert sich jetzt da aber eher um
organisatorische Dinger.
Versteh den Hype um Monster Hunter gar nicht.
Hab es 3 Stunden gespielt und dann
vor Langeweile ausgebaut.
Ich kann dazu nix sagen.
Ich hab das neue Monster Hunter noch gar nicht ausprobiert.
Ich wollte es mit dem Fabian spielen.
Wir wollten es uns einfach mal angucken.
Weil es ja auch Leute ansprechen soll
wie mich, die quasi mit Monster Hunter
bisher nicht so viel anfangen konnten.
Wer macht
deiner Meinung nach die besten
Mäuse Tastaturen Headsets?
Headsets?
Biodynamics?
Also es gibt
eigentlich...
Es gibt eigentlich nix was über das
Mx300 geht.
Immer noch, wenn man die Kohle hat.
Oder mal ein bisschen
gespart hat.
Wir sind im Magen gelandet anscheinend.
Mäuse Tastaturen.
Mäuse
würde ich sagen
an sich hätte ich immer gesagt Logitech.
Aber ich hab jetzt ja
wie gesagt, ich hatte ja lange
zum testen die
G502 glaube ich
oder war es G402
Pro Toys Core
oder wie dieses Ding hieß.
Die war mir zu schwer.
Und ich hab seitdem von Zoe
also das ist BenQ
die EC2A. Da gibt es jetzt mittlerweile auch
die EC2B glaube ich.
Irgendwie so eine Neuauflage davon.
Und ich muss sagen, das ist so eine simple Maus
die hat nix.
Das ist einfach eine Maus mit zwei Seitentasten
und eine Maus mit zwei Knöpfen links und rechts.
Die finde ich richtig gut.
Und Tastaturen würde ich ausprobieren
was mir gefällt. Also ich würde sagen
ein MMX300
von Biodynamics
oder eben irgendein x-beliebiges
gutes Audio Kopfhörer
und ein ModMic dabei.
Dann für mich hier eine Zoe EC2A
mit der
sogar Taimo spielt.
Na gut, der spielt jetzt ja nicht mal mehr DPS
aber das ist einfach mein Lieblings
Overwatch Spieler.
Und Tastatur kein Schimmer.
Was müssen wir jetzt hier bauen?
Also ich muss sagen, die Level sind echt
kreativ gemacht hier.
Ich glaube irgendwie
ich muss nach unten bauen, kann das sein?
Sodass es nicht mehr so hin und her wackelt jetzt erstmal.
Weil solange das hier so hin und her wackelt
ist das ziemlich kacke.
Solange das hier so hin und her wackelt wird das hier nix.
Äh nein, so wird das auch so nix.
Moment, bleiben die an den Wänden hängen?
Bleiben die an den Wänden hängen?
Nicht wirklich, oder?
Ja, das haben wir schon gelesen.
Gucken wir mal.
Jeff, wie spooft.
Das hängt nicht so wirklich an.
Bleibt nicht so wirklich an der Wand hängen.
Hallo Relic Gaming HD.
Jetzt hängt es.
Bisschen zumindest.
Oder auch nicht.
Jeff, soll das funktionieren?
Ich glaube ich muss es nach unten bauen.
Ich glaube ich muss das nach unten bauen.
Aber gucken wir mal.
Wir bauen es jetzt einfach mal nach oben.
Aber jetzt ist es zu schwer, jetzt spooft es nicht mehr.
Jetzt können wir nämlich hier nochmal nach rechts bauen.
Ja, so ist das gut.
Jetzt steckt es fest.
Nicht umkippen! Nein! Oh fuck.
Es wird nicht schön, aber es wird funktionieren.
Ich sag's euch, easy.
Es wird easiest level überhaupt werden.
Okay, wie soll das jetzt genau funktionieren?
Wie geht man jetzt hier durch?
Ich glaube das Ziel ist einfach nur rauszukommen.
Es gibt überhaupt kein Limit.
Und wir gehen langsam die Bälle aus.
Wobei ich kann die ja unten ab...
Wow, wow, wow.
Okay, was steht auf dem Schild?
Okay, ich muss fliegen.
Fliegt man damit?
Der Typ, der das Spiel gebaut hat, hat echt coole Ideen.
Es sieht zwar nicht elegant aus, aber es funktioniert.
Flieg.
Will nicht.
Und hopp.
Abgehoben.
Oh, Story Mode.
Easy Clap.
Wenn das erst Chapter 1 gewesen ist,
und mich das an dem einen Level schon so überfordert hat,
will ich erst gar nicht wissen, was Chapter 2 wird.
Okay, ich scroll mal kurz Chat hoch.
Noch ein bisschen was übersehen.
Wie lange die Mainquests gehen in BDO?
Stunden.
Ewig.
Die gehen bis in die Wüste.
Und danach gibt es noch mal einen,
die gehen noch mal quer durch die Welt.
Ewig gehen die Mainquests.
Gucken, wie schwierig Chapter 2 wird.
Oh, guck mal.
Neue Balls.
Ah, die wiegen bestimmt nix.
Oder wenig.
Die wiegen wenig.
Da kann man sich hier runterhangeln.
Wir hangeln uns jetzt hier runter.
Dann holen wir die Goobelle von da unten.
Aufwachen.
Und dann müssen wir irgendwie da rein.
Stell ich mir relativ schwierig vor.
Ja, Sibaro.
In BDO machst du immer Kreiselgrind.
Egal ob Mainquest oder nicht.
Ich hab die Mainquest selbst noch nicht mal durchgemacht.
Wie lange geht das Stream heute?
Keine Ahnung.
Oh, jetzt wird's natürlich schwierig.
Jetzt müssen wir irgendwie hier rein.
Die sind für Wassertropfen verdammt stabil,
sag ich euch.
Ich ahne Schlimmes.
Leute, ich ahne Schlimmes.
Ich muss das in die entgegengesetzte Richtung
noch bauen, oder?
Das wird doch sonst...
Kann man die Wassertropfen voneinander wieder abdingsen?
Nee, kann man nicht.
Ich glaub, ich muss da nochmal kurz in die entgegengesetzte Richtung bauen,
sonst fällt das wieder runter.
Wobei, komm, scheiß drauf.
Komm jetzt, komm jetzt.
Jawoll! Easy!
Einfach nicht zu sehr überdenken.
Einfach machen.
Hast du eigentlich so Kartenspiele wie Magic
oder Yu-Gi-Oh! gespielt?
Ja, ich hab Yu-Gi-Oh! gespielt.
Oh, und die, die die Serie geguckt haben,
gedacht haben, sie wissen Bescheid.
Oh, jetzt muss ich erstmal da drüber fliegen, ha?
Vor mal.
Ja. Okay.
Hui!
Okay, jetzt muss ich irgendwie da drüber kommen.
Ey, das funktioniert.
Oh, das ist natürlich
ganz schön... Oh, das ist übertriebenes
Gefummel.
Aber
kein Ding.
Gehen wir hin.
Und wo muss ich überhaupt hinfliegen?
Ich flieg jetzt hier rüber, dann
lande ich hier. Jetzt hab ich rückgängig gemacht.
Das ist ganz toll.
Dann lande ich hier und dann
hangel ich mich hier runter zur
Röhre.
Klingt nach einem guten Plan, so machen wir das.
Der Sound ist toll.
So, jetzt sind wir hier drüber.
Sind wir drüber? Na, ein Stück
kommen wir noch rüber.
So, jetzt fliegen wir runter.
Der Max hat schon immer
Loops geoppt.
Am Anfang, als die ganzen
Leute diese komische Yu-Gi-Oh! Fernsehserie
geguckt haben, war es auch geil.
Die meisten Leute haben sich ja null
mit dem Game beschäftigt.
Ich weiß leider auch... Ich hab wieder fast
alles vergessen.
Ich glaube, Yu-Gi-Oh! hatte ja
gar keine feste Kartenbeschränkung.
Also, du konntest theoretisch so viele
Karten nehmen, wie du willst.
Ähm, da bin ich mir jetzt aber
nicht mal so ganz sicher.
Oder zumindest war die Anzahl
der Karten, die du nehmen konntest,
so hoch, dass keiner maximale Anzahl
genommen hat.
Und du hattest halt irgendwelche Leute, die haben dann
den ganzen Bullshit reingepackt.
Ja, also irgendwie dieser komische blaue Drache
aus der Serie haben alle, obwohl
die überhaupt keine Monster dazu hatten, um das Ding zu beschwören.
Und da hattest du dann halt diese
Totenkopfkarte.
Ich hab das
alles vergessen, wie das Zeug hieß.
Dieser Totenkopf, den du quasi
äh, so die beste
Karte damals, die du direkt beschwören konntest.
Oder
eine der besten. Und
die haben halt rumgegangen
mit Billigmonstern, weil sie
halt so einen auf geiler
Typ wie aus der Serie machen wollten.
Wobei, es gibt ja auf Youtube
ähm, viele
viele Videos, die die
Yu-Gi-Oh! Serie ein bisschen analysiert haben.
Und quasi mal erzählen,
was die eigentlich in der Serie
für eine Scheiße spielen, ne?
Die laut Regeln überhaupt nicht erlaubt
ist. So, ich geh mal davon aus,
ich muss jetzt hier rüber fliegen.
Und dann hier mit diesen, mit den
kleinen, mit den Wasserguß
das
Zeug
rüber
runter, runter
tröpfeln lassen, ne?
Wir machen mal ein Ballon
weg, weil wir wollen ein bisschen tiefer fliegen.
Ne, wir müssen noch ein bisschen
rüber. So, hä?
Ja, das ist gut, das passt.
Fliegen.
Okay.
Das, das sieht doch ganz, das sieht doch ganz gut aus.
Guck.
Ne, das hängt jetzt aber nicht gerade gerade.
Kann ich, kann ich
einen auch hier hin machen? Hängt's dann gerade?
Ja.
Ja, das sieht ganz gut aus.
Plopp.
Plopp. Jawoll!
Überhaupt kein Ding.
Alles gepackt. Ne?
Next.
PogChamp.
So realistische Physik.
Was, Pavillon Man, es gibt ne neue
Yu-Gi-Oh! Serie, wirklich?
Ich hab, ich hab, ich hab,
ich glaube, ich bin einer wenige, die das gespielt haben,
aber nie wirklich die Serie geguckt haben.
Klar, ab und zu mal irgendwelche Folgen oder so,
aber ich fand das irgendwie bescheuert.
Vor allem halt
dieses typische Zeug, so wie es halt in
Yu-Gi-Oh! immer gewesen ist. Oh mein Gott!
Ah! Weißt du, wenn man
von irgendwas getroffen wurde, was ja
laut dieser Serie nur, nur, nur quasi
Hologramm war, ne? Da kommt dann
irgendein Monster, attackiert, und es
ist halt, sogar in der Story von der Serie,
es ist halt nur ein Hologramm, es ist halt nicht echt,
ja? Und die Leute, und dann in der Serie
immer dann alle, alle Charaktere,
wenn sie gehittet werden,
fand ich schon damals übelst bescheuert.
Vor allem, wenn sie dann immer angekündigt haben,
den, den Scheiß, so, ich beschwöre
jetzt, was weiß ich,
krasser ohne 8000,
haben sie es dann beschwört, ne?
Und, und, und da kommt dann der andere,
da kommt dann, da antwortet dann der andere Typ in,
in diesem Duell dann, das kannst du nicht tun!
Und dann sagt dann der andere noch,
ha, du wirst sehen, wie ich das kann, aber
nicht, wenn ich jetzt meine Fallenkarte
das war, das war dann immer so,
das ging mir, ich hab das nie großartig
geguckt.
Das war richtig beknackt eigentlich.
Und dann haben sie immer so getan, in der
Serie, als wären sie jetzt voll überrascht,
so, oh mein Gott, nein, das geht doch nicht!
Und dann, nächste Runde,
steht er dann so da, ha, ha, ha,
damit habe ich gerechnet, dass
du diese Karte jetzt spielst, ha, ha,
und deswegen beschwöre ich jetzt die einzige
Karte, die es in dem Spiel gibt, die genau dagegen
wirkt.
Richtig eng geblieben.
Ähm, oh, das
sieht kompliziert aus.
Wie heißt denn das Level nochmal?
Steht nicht da.
Oh, ich glaub, da
der Schildermaler
möchte uns irgendwie die Story von
World of Goo näherbringen.
Was, es gibt mittlerweile sechs Serien, die fangen
ja immer wieder mit neuem Charakter an. Achso!
Da sind andere
echt, wie gesagt,
null beschäftigt. So, wie funktioniert denn
das Ganze hier jetzt?
Ich hab nur, ich hab nur Wasser
Guss? Oder?
Die schwarzen Dinger
gehen eigentlich nicht. Okay, ich glaube,
ich hab ungefähr gecheckt, was ich machen muss.
Ich hab immer so meine Zweifel, ob das
funktioniert.
Wobei, das, das könnte schon funktionieren.
So, und jetzt machen wir im Endeffekt,
jetzt bauen wir hier vorne ein
und dann haben wir direkt einen Luftballon
dran. Ja, das funktioniert.
Und dann muss ich,
oh, dann muss ich über diese Windmühle drüber
bauen.
Game, ernsthaft jetzt, ja? Und dann, wo muss
ich hin? Oh, ob das
was wird? Das heißt, ich muss mich jetzt hier mit
Luftballon hochhangeln und dann
quasi mit dem Wind mich irgendwie...
Na, da wollen wir mal.
Easy Clap, das ist überhaupt
kein Ding.
Wisst ihr, Leute, ich hab's
schon immer gesagt, es ist immer
alles easy, bis man
sagt, es ist nicht easy.
Deswegen ist das einfachste Level überhaupt
hier.
Das ist schon too easy.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Der Luftballonsound, der macht einen so ein bisschen
ein bisschen komisch
im Kopf, ne?
Okay, okay, eigentlich sind wir hoch genug.
Was passiert jetzt, wenn ich hier so ein Ding dranhänge?
Schwebt das dann schon im Wind?
Das schwebt schon im Wind, okay.
Nicht so ganz. Okay, wir müssen noch mal eins
weitermachen. So, ich glaube,
das reicht. Und jetzt hängen
wir die dran und dann lassen wir uns hier runterhängen.
Guck mal, guck mal, das passt.
Ich müsste ziemlich genau da rauskommen, glaube ich.
Ich hoffe nur, die Physik verhält sich so, wie ich mir das gedacht habe.
Äh,
hier habe ich noch einen.
Wir müssen das hier ein bisschen höher machen,
in der Mitte.
Ja, ja, das funktioniert.
Ja,
das klappt, das klappt, das klappt, das klappt.
Das klappt, das klappt, das klappt schon.
Easy, guck, guck mal, Anna.
Oh,
oh, oh, wir sind zu weit.
Wir sind viel,
sind viel zu weit.
Oh, doch, es hängt mit dem
Kabel, es hängt runter. Perfekt.
Okay, so richtig funktioniert das noch nicht.
Dann müssen wir hier noch ein paar abmachen
und dahinter hängen.
Dann sollten die hier weiter runterfallen.
Ja,
gut, sehr gut.
Sieh auf, wir kommen der Sache näher.
Perfekt. Komm, jetzt noch ein Stückchen,
noch ein Stückchen.
Okay, okay.
Ja, ja,
ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, komm, komm.
Jawoll!
Oh, oh, oh, nicht, nicht, nicht
kaputt gehen jetzt. Komm, es fehlen nicht mal viel.
Es fehlen nicht mal viel Goo Balls.
Macht hinne.
Oh, war das knapp.
Fuck,
das war knapp.
Ist noch, ist noch eingebrochen.
Monka X, da reicht Monka S
nicht mehr, da brauchen wir Monka X für.
Hab ich, hab ich eigentlich, Moment.
Hab ich noch nicht mal freigeschaltet.
Ah, ja, ja.
Okay, hast du irgendwas übersehen im,
im Chat?
Hast du mal Subnautica gespielt? Nein.
Ich hab mir das
mal irgendwo auf Steam,
als das noch Early, war das,
das war Early Access, ne, oder
war das in Beta oder so, mal angeguckt.
Also, wurde empfohlen in, in,
in Steam Store.
Hab ich mir gedacht, so, ne,
auf Survival
unter Wasser stellen, das hab ich keine Lust.
Wie sich jetzt alle erzählen, wie sie die O.G.
Serie angeguckt haben.
Genau, das Spiel der Schatten,
das gab's auch noch, ja.
Sowas, was, was komplett, was es in der,
in der Originalfassung nie gegeben hat.
Wie findest du D-LAN,
findest du D-LAN ist deine Alternative
zu W-LAN? Nö.
Weil W-LAN funktioniert überall, D-LAN funktioniert nur da,
wo Steckdosen sind.
Es ist überhaupt keine Alternative zu W-LAN.
Wie, wie, wie willst du mit D-LAN
in deine Gartenhütte
Internetversorgung kriegen?
Wenn du da sitzt und grillst und
irgendwie WLAN-Empfang haben willst.
D-LAN ist höchstens eine Alternative
zu Netzwerkkabel legen.
Im Haus.
Und selbst da muss ich sagen,
also,
wenn man irgendwie,
irgendwie Sinn kriegt, Netzwerkkabel
zu legen, würd ich Netzwerkkabel legen, anstatt
diesen, über Strom
Netzwerk-Zeugs
da.
Holst du dieses Jahr
kein neues Kaspersky?
Ja, das ist ne gute Entscheidung.
Was hältst du von
Monster Hunter World? Ich hab's noch nicht gespielt.
Ich wollte das mit dem, mit dem Fabian ja spielen.
Hier fehlen FFZ-E-Modes.
Wie, wie macht man denn
FFZ-E-Modes?
Gibt's da so ne Seite wie bei BellaTwitchTV,
wo man, wo man FFZ-E-Modes
irgendwie freischalten kann?
Da mach ich das nämlich nachher gleich.
Guckst du irgendwelche Serienfilme?
Ähm, ne.
Also ich guck generell wenig,
wenig, äh,
so klassische Sachen.
Klar, ich guck ab und zu mal nen Film auf Amazon,
aber Serien
wenig. Das letzte,
was war das letzte, was ich geguckt hab?
True Detectives hab ich, glaub ich, geguckt.
Das fand ich dann schlecht. Davor hab ich mal
Black Sails geguckt.
Pirate Stealths.
Und jetzt müsst ich mal nachgucken.
Ich müsste jetzt mal bei Amazon gucken,
was ich mir da geholt hab.
Ich hab schon ein paar Sachen geguckt, war
es gibt schon ein paar ganz coole Filme, so.
Aber, ähm,
das Problem ist, ich merk's immer wieder,
wir bleiben die Sachen meistens nicht in Erinnerung.
Und das spricht jetzt nicht unbedingt
für das Zeug. Moment mal, Leute,
ich guck jetzt mal.
Was ich bei Amazon, was hab ich,
was hab ich zuletzt bei Amazon geguckt?
Das kann man bestimmt,
das kann man bestimmt sortieren, oder?
Kann man Amazon Bestellung nach
Video sortieren? Ja.
True Detectives
Staffel 1 hab ich geguckt.
Simon's Cat
Volume 1. Haha, jetzt weiß ich das immer
wenn ich auf YouTube guck.
Der hat einen Film in Farbe gemacht, das hab ich mir noch geholt.
Was hab ich denn geguckt? The Accountant hab ich geschaut.
Arlo und Spot, ja so Animationsfilme,
da steh ich ja drauf.
Die Graus in the Shell
Realverfilmung hab ich geguckt.
John Wick, ähm, Passengers.
Was hab ich denn noch so?
Black Sails.
Staffel 1, 2, 3, 4.
Deadpool.
Ja, also
ich hab schon ein paar Filme geguckt.
Ich hab richtig krasse Erinnerungen.
Also, ich muss sagen, der Film, der mir
in den letzten Jahren am meisten in Erinnerung
geblieben ist, wo ich sagen muss,
der ist nicht wirklich gut,
aber der ist voll abgedreht, das war
Hardcore Henry.
Das ist mir echt, falls das jemand kennt,
das ist mir echt in Erinnerung geblieben.
Wahrscheinlich gefällt das bloß Leuten,
die COD spielen oder so.
Oder Battlefield, keine Ahnung.
Ich fand das übelst geil.
Einfach mal einen Film komplett mit GoPros gedreht.
Oder eben mit irgendwelchen
Actioncams.
Moment, was muss ich hier eigentlich machen?
Ähm.
Hardcore was? Hardcore Henry.
Wie heißt das?
Das haben sie irgendwie,
das ist quasi komplett aus Ego-Perspektive gedreht.
So mit irgendwelchen Actioncams.
Das fand ich übelst geil.
Das war, ich mein, der Film
ist objektiv, ja? Also wenn
jetzt irgendwie so der krasse Kritiker
ähm
hingeht.
Und der zerreißt
den Film, ja? Also wirklich gut ist der
nicht, aber der ist geil gemacht.
Ich muss übrigens mal gucken, ob ich
noch mehr D-Abos bekommen hab, weil irgendwelche Leute
sich wieder auf den Schlips getreten gefühlt haben,
weil ich den Virenscanner schlecht gemacht hab.
Ja. Zwei, drei
mehr oder so. Ich find das so geil,
wie die Leute mit sowas Probleme
haben, ey.
Lol. Ich glaub ich muss das hochheben.
Ja.
Kein Ding.
Und
jetzt muss ich
Was muss ich denn jetzt machen?
Jetzt muss ich hier wahrscheinlich die grünen
Gooballs andocken, dass
ich mich hier hochschaufeln kann.
Vermute ich mal.
Keine Ahnung, ob das irgendwie stimmt, was ich hier mache.
Äh.
Na, ob das so klappt?
Wow, wow. Wow.
Wow.
Dass das so
gedacht ist?
Ich mein, ich brauch 36. Das sind ordentlich
viele, die hier rumschwimmen. Oh, da unten ist
noch was. Gucken wir
doch mal. Gucken wir mal, ob das reicht.
Ob ich genug gerettet hab.
Deswegen braucht man auch die ganzen
Ballons, weil man so viel hat.
Moin,
Halbkorn.
Magst streamen oder magst Video
gucken? Ja. Das ist schwierig.
Ich würd sagen, magst streamen, weil es geht nicht mehr so lange,
und dann kannst du Video gucken.
Ich muss ja morgen wieder arbeiten. Das heißt, ich muss dann irgendwann
auch demnächst pennen. Oh.
So, jetzt gucken wir mal, wie viel wir haben.
Genug,
genug. Überhaupt kein Ding.
von 36. Da kann ja wirklich nichts
schiefgehen.
Zu gute Auflösung für den Stream.
Tja, äh, Streamer zu gute
Auflösung für dich.
Ja, ich krieg ja heute keine Quality
Options.
Ich guck mal. Ich weiß ja nicht, was ich dagegen machen soll,
ehrlich gesagt.
Ich hatte immer Quality Options. Ich weiß nicht, wo die
jetzt hin sind. Vielleicht möchte
mir Twitch damit auch sagen. Ich soll sie mal
anschreiben wegen, äh, ne, Partner
und so.
Kann ja sein.
Subbutton, easy.
Beauty School.
Stream mit 30 FPS,
du hast Quality Options. Ne, ich hab
am Anfang 1080p 30
FPS gestreamt und ich hatte auch keine Quality Options.
Deswegen hab ich, ähm,
dann umgeschaltet
und jetzt hab ich auch keine Quality Options.
Das letzte Mal, ja.
Hatte ich das.
Weiß nicht wo. Und das letzte Mal waren's auch 48
FPS, was ich probiert hab.
War das nicht früher sogar so, dass nur
Varifieds Auflösung hatten?
Äh, keine Ahnung. Ich hatte immer
Quality Options. Egal mit was ich gestreamt hab bisher.
Ich hab immer bisher mit 6 Mbit
gestreamt, 6 Mbit, entweder
1080p 30 oder
7720 60. Oder
48. Hat immer Quality Options.
Ich probier das das nächste Mal aus.
Ich stell dann wieder auf 30. Mal gucken, ob's dann funktioniert.
Außerdem soll Twitch allgemein, Twitch muss
mal langsam ein bisschen
mehr als 6 Mbit erlauben.
Was ist das?
Ein Grill-Goo.
Also wenn,
wenn Twitch das hinkriegt,
dass man, dass man, sagen wir mal
mit 8 Mbit, 8 Mbit
wär schon, sogar 7
fänd ich schon gut.
6 Mbit ist einfach für 1080p
ein bisschen wenig.
Sagen wir mal 8, 8 Mbit. Am besten wär
natürlich 10.
Aber sagen wir mal, sagen wir mal, diese
können's doch so machen wie YouTube.
Ich mein, da ist Amazon mittlerweile dahinter.
Die haben ja nicht zu wenig Rechenleistung oder so.
Könnten doch einfach
sagen, äh, wir erlauben
1440p
mit 15 Mbit.
So, und dann transcoden sie das irgendwie.
Ich mein, ich weiß, das kostet
ordentlich Rechenleistung, ja.
Aber es wär ja okay, wenn man das für
Streams macht, die ein bisschen Zuschauer haben.
Das muss doch funktionieren. So, was muss
ich denn hier überhaupt machen?
Wer ist der hübscheste Goo-Ball?
Tja.
Das Goo-Ball-Grill.
Wow.
Sollte das jetzt wegfliegen?
Oh. Leute.
Wir müssen das Goo-Ball-Grill
zerstören. Seht ihr das?
Das ist ja tragisch.
Wahrscheinlich kommen jetzt die Feministen in
meinen Stream und wollen, dass ich
gelöscht werde, weil ich das
Goo-Ball-Grill
da reinwerfen muss.
Instant Band.
Holst du dir Kingdom Come Deliverance? Ne.
Was war dieses
Asia-Hacken-slash-Diablo-
Style-Game, ne?
Hallo, Alex.
Wieso die das machen?
Oh, Storytime.
Ich versteh die Story nicht.
Ich find, sie
sollten es erlauben, dass du in
guter Qualität zu Twitch
streamst und dann sollen sie das
halt transcoden. Da können sie sagen, okay,
die Leute, die
eine fett genug Leitung haben, können
sich das quasi Source angucken.
1440p mit Kanal 15nm.
Und die anderen werden halt runtergerechnet auf
sagen wir mal
8 für 1080p
oder sagen wir mal auf 6 für 720p.
Das wär halt sehr praktisch.
Es sieht einfach... Twitch
ist die Seite mit der hässlichsten
Videoqualität. Also die
Stream-Seite mit der hässlichsten Videoqualität.
Aber trotzdem
gleichzeitig die Beste.
Das liegt halt nicht an der Videoqualität.
Sondern an einem anderen Drumherum.
Als Partner geht das
bestimmt. Wobei, als Partner
kriegst du auch nicht mehr Bitrate. Oder nur ganz
ganz zu ganz speziellen
Anlässen. Also hier.
DanzGaming hat ja auch
der streamt ja auch nur irgendwas mit 6
bis 7 Mbit. Also der kriegt auch nicht mehr.
Was muss ich denn hier machen
jetzt? Ich muss wieder
den Scooball-Grill kaputt machen.
Pretty Flower.
What happens when you get closer?
Das wollen wir ausprobieren.
Die Pipe sackt.
Also ich vermute mal, was ich jetzt machen muss
ist hier einfach hoch bauen.
Bis, bis, bis
das Scooball-Grill
hier oben in den Häcksler gesaugt wird.
Dann fallen die Scooballs
hier runter.
Und hier unten durch.
So stell ich mir das gerade vor.
Gucken ob das so funktioniert.
Oh, da muss ich aufpassen, dass
es nicht runterfällt.
Da muss man aufpassen.
Pass auf.
Nein, nein, nein, nicht runterfallen.
Okay, bauen wir jetzt erstmal
hier so einen Rand, dass er nicht mehr
runterfallen kann.
So.
Dann hier neben hoch.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das sinnvoll ist, was ich hier mache.
Ich weiß gar nicht so genau, was...
Was macht denn
die Blume da?
Ich probier erstmal das Scooball...
Das Scooball-Grill.
Oh, fuck.
Dann hab ich hier weiter hochzuheben.
Okay, und du?
Ich bin mir nicht so ganz sicher, ob das stimmt,
was ich hier mache, ehrlich gesagt.
So, ich mein, jetzt kann ja eigentlich
nichts mehr passieren, wenn ich das so baue, ne?
Okay, jetzt
geben wir mal Vollgas und schleudern sie hier raus.
Okay, oder auch nicht.
Wir haben doch nicht immer so
viele Balls.
Einen Ball haben wir noch. Achtung, Leute.
Volle Pulle.
Jawoll!
Hier, äh, hier.
Jetzt schreckt.
Okay, das funktioniert.
Und jetzt muss ich
nach da unten.
Was ja eigentlich heißt, ich muss den ganzen
Scheiß hier abbauen. Wobei, jetzt...
Nein, jetzt muss ich wahrscheinlich einfach zur Blume hin.
Jawoll!
900 IQ-Plays.
Blub.
Das war too easy.
Twitch-Arbeit-Gerater
am IRL-Kram.
Ja, es... kann ja...
auch verstehen. Also, ich würd mir wünschen, dass
Twitch generell ein bisschen an...
Also, IRL
ist das eine. Ich fänd's gut, wenn die an
Creative arbeiten.
Weil es gibt viele Leute, die...
Ich sag mal so, gehen wir mal von dem Stream
aus, den ich gestern gemacht hab. Es gibt viele Leute,
die programmieren irgendwas.
Was mit Sicherheit auch mehr Leute
interessiert, als die vier, fünf Sachen, die es
jetzt halt zufällig grade in Creative finden.
Oder Leute, die malen
irgendwas, die, keine Ahnung,
die, die falten irgendwelche krassen Papierfiguren,
die basteln irgendwas.
Ähm, es gibt... Kennt ihr den, den
Dings hier, den Piano-Impro-Man?
Das ist auch übelst geil.
Gucken teilweise nur 30 Leute zu.
Und dabei ist das... Das ist mega nice,
ja? Der Piano-Impro-Man.
Könnt mal gucken, ob der überhaupt
online ist, quasi, grade.
Dann hosten wir den nämlich nachher.
Der Piano-Impro-Man.
Ja,
der ist sogar online.
Das ist mega nice. Und das guckt man, wenn man... Das ist mega nice. Und das guckt man, wenn man... Das ist mega nice. Und das guckt man, wenn man...
kaum einer. Bei ihm gucken grad 27 Leute zu.
Also, die...
Ich, ich fänd's gut, wenn Twitch an Creative
arbeitet noch.
Oder eben IHL und Creative
verschmilzt. Weil ich mein, du brauchst...
Du brauchst nicht Talkshow, IHL,
Creative, Programming, das muss ja eigentlich
alles sein. Entweder machen sie...
Warum sollte Programming
nicht für IHL sein?
Beauty and the Electric Tentacle.
Wie heißt der Typ? Piano-Impro-Man.
Ich hoste den nachher.
Der ist übelst geil, der Typ. Wow.
Was ist das?
Wieder ein Goo-Ball-Grill.
Oh, Story.
Story intensifies.
Okay, wir müssen wieder irgendwelche...
Dinger bauen.
Ich vermute mal, ich muss das...
Ich muss den... den...
Grill-Ball hier hochheben.
Ja.
Okay, das sieht nicht so schwierig aus bis jetzt,
muss ich sagen. Wir müssen hier einfach rüber
und dann... Oh!
Äh...
Und dann das... das... das...
Das Grill hier wieder in den Häcksler
werfen. Und dann
sollte das... sollte das tun.
Oh, das sagt, ich muss gleich
off, gleich pennen.
Hab überhaupt keinen Bock.
Oh, wir müssen mal
ein bisschen...
Lauf-Balance, zack, komm her.
Okay, okay,
okay.
Eigentlich... eigentlich haben wir's jetzt ja mehr oder weniger.
So.
Jetzt lassen wir's hier rüberrollen.
Nein, so nicht.
Aber fast.
Ja, genau so.
Zack.
Ich dachte immer, IT-Firmen fangen erst zum Neuen an.
Nee, ich kann... ich kann fast
anfangen, wann ich will. Solange...
Solange
der Empfang auf ist. Und selbst dann könnte ich
mit der Karte ins... ins Haus.
Ich mein, ich... wahrscheinlich würde
sich irgendwann mal die Personalabteilung melden.
Wenn ich stundenlang
oder Tage... nicht stundenlang, tagelang
äh, um 3 Uhr
oder so, ne? Das glaub ich nicht,
dass das so gehen würde. Aber ich kann ohne
Probleme schon um kurz vor 7
anfangen. Das hat halt den großen Vorteil, wenn ich kurz
nach 7 da bin,
dass ich dann 15 Uhr wieder abhauen kann.
Kurz nach 15 Uhr.
Das ist natürlich sehr, sehr nice.
It's not a bug, it's a feature.
Hä?
Machst du kein Mittag?
Doch, ich hab
in der... in der Arbeitszeit hab ich... hab ich ne halbe
Stunde Mittagspause mit drin.
Also die... die... die muss ich
nehmen, da bleibt mir nix anderes übrig.
Ähm...
Muss ich jetzt hier unten abbauen?
Ich glaube nicht, dass das so gedacht
ist, wie ich das gerade
gemacht habe.
Ah, so ist das gedacht!
Aha!
Fuck!
Oh, ich bin dumm! Ich muss das... ich muss das oben
vorher abmachen.
Ups, was mach ich denn da?
Ah, jetzt funktioniert's.
Hui!
Okay, Leute, es ist 21.30 Uhr.
Das war heute
leider ein etwas kürzerer Stream wie gestern.
Gestern war ja übertrieben lang. Gestern waren 8 Stunden.
Oder? Ich guck mal. 7,5 Stunden
gestern. Heute
haben wir es nur auf 2 gebracht.
Ich muss aber leider
Schluss machen.
Wer noch nicht auf YouTube gewesen ist
und mal ein Video geguckt hat, kann sich ja mal...
Was?
The Whistle.
Das heißt, ich kann jetzt pfeifen.
Ja, wer noch nicht mal ein Video geguckt hat,
kann ja mal bei YouTube reinschauen.
Wer jetzt nur hier über Twitch dabei ist,
ich freu mich natürlich über Follows
auf allen möglichen Seiten. Natürlich erstmal
hier auf Twitch. Auf Twitter,
auf YouTube.
Das einzige, wo ich keinen Bock drauf hab, ist Facebook.
Auch wenn ich Facebook... Ich hab zwar einen Facebook-Account,
den hab ich aber nur, um ihn zu haben.
Ich find, Facebook ist die beschissenste
Social-Media-Plattform von allen.
Ich hoffe, euch hat's gefallen.
Und wir machen jetzt Schluss.
Dann sehen wir uns wahrscheinlich
morgen. Bis denn.
Macht's gut. Tschüss.